be honest no if we had said nothing and
just let your birthday go by
you wouldn't have liked that right I
would have had something to be bitter
about oh so which as Sona will tell you
is the greatest gift that would have
been your yeah a good gift would have
been to forget my birthday and then I
could have hated you for it but I also
get to hate you for bringing it up that
you're 60. yeah okay there you go one
more time 60. exactly can I say
something though you take good care of
yourself I do you are exactly the same
at least to me in terms of your
physicality and the things that you do
from when I first started working for
you that's why I don't think you'd be
upset because you look good you sound
good I've I listen I'm thinking of
having a lot of work done oh and I know
that uh that's not necessary for a
podcast
what are you gonna get done oh your
boobs I want big boobs
I want huge boobs
and I also want those butt imp what I
would get done is butt implants because
I have no ass